If it's about overcoming Chofu, then it's psychology.
What do you mean by appreciating it? In
short, I wonder if it's good if I can feel fear as fun
Hurry up tomorrow and
start your same kind of training.
Even if you catch too much rope masa
ame
Next time, how about this? One
way to overcome the strong wind is to let your body remember that the target is safe
by getting used to Chofu.
I mean, if you can meet, you won't have to worry about it, but I think you should try something close to
it.
I'm going to sell it
Wow,
this is a substitute for the arc I guess if you get killed before you get used to it, it's
oil after all, so I'll stop it
No,
I've got to get
back a 9
[music]